she was a singer-songwriter a beloved
mother and Elvis Presley's only child
tonight we remember the life of Lisa
Marie Presley welcome everyone to
Entertainment Tonight let's get right to
Kevin Frazier right now who's at the TCL
Chinese Theater in Hollywood Kev the
Presley family was just honored there in
June I was there Michelle we're not sure
where or when but officials here at the
Chinese Theater told me that very soon
they will install those hand prints here
in the four Court of the Chinese Theater
you know we're just one block away from
her father's star on the Walk of Fame it
really does feel surreal that we were
just with her on the red carpet at the
Golden Globes and now she's gone let's
take a look back at the final days of
Lisa Marie Presley
we just celebrated your dad's birthday a
couple days ago
so what does it mean to you to be here
tonight you know I'm just so proud of it
all it's all flowing really nicely
together I'm gonna have the birthday
right now and you know I'm here to
support Austin and film and I'm so
excited and I hope he wins Lisa Marie
who looked fragile as she left the ET
stage Tuesday night went into full
Cardiac Arrest less than 48 hours later
here at her Calabasas home the 54 year
old was reportedly discovered
unresponsive in the bedroom by her
housekeeper full arrest at 10 37 a.m
paramedics were dispatched they
performed CPR and determined she had
Signs of Life Lisa Marie was then rushed
to this nearby hospital where her mother
Priscilla held vigil
over the last few months with the
release of Elvis Lisa Marie struggled
with her emotions I'm so overwhelmed by
this film and the effect that it's had
that's her Saturday night in Hollywood
heading into a party to celebrate the
film on what would have been the king's
88th birthday on Sunday she was at
Graceland in Memphis addressing fans and
you're the only people that can bring me
out of my house
see I'm not kidding
at her side for the emotional homecoming
and throughout the Elvis press tour
grief expert David Kessler he comforted
the family outside the hospital we also
saw Lisa Marie back in June she was with
Austin Butler at a hand and footprint
ceremony in Hollywood watching him play
your file it did something to me it
really did and so what did it do to you
oh a lot a lot I wasn't ready for what
it did I really wasn't now over the
years Lisa Marie has had her fair share
of financial troubles we learned that
she recently signed a book deal and
receives an advance of 500 000 back in
2016 it was divulged that she was
reportedly 16 million dollars in debt
she blamed it on a nasty divorce and her
ex-business partner who sold off the
rights to her father's music and image
there is one Legacy Lisa Marie held on
to Graceland this morning we confirm
this is where Lisa Marie's final resting
place will be right next to her beloved
Son Ben and just a few feet away from
her father I toured the estate with her
mother Priscilla back in 2008. Lisa
Marie told me the childhood home held so
many special memories for her and by the
way to calm everyone down
it's your house it's never going to be
sold because it seems like every once
while those rumors pop up I know they're
popping up regularly it's not it isn't
it's absolutely 100 mine always has been
mine Graceland always will be and when
it's no longer mine it would be my
children's you know that's that among
the many celebrity tributes ex-husband
Nicholas Cage tells E.T Lisa had the
greatest laugh of anyone I ever met I am
heartbroken and from her ex Michael
Jackson's nephew TJ she was always so
sweet to my brothers and me have you
gotten completely out from under the
weight of the the Presley name do you
think I think it'd be very naive to
state that I that that would ever happen
you know completely
[Music]
Lisa Marie mirrored her famous dad in
many ways talented singer devoted parent
but also a troubled soul her father died
when she was just nine years old she saw
his dead body inside Graceland Linda
Thompson Elvis's ex remembers the phone
call August 16 1977 Lisa Marie called me
and she blurted out my daddy's dad my
daddy's dad nearly five years earlier
her parents had divorced and Lisa Marie
was having a hard time adjusting he was
not strict at all
my mom is completely the opposite she
was really strict so it was very
confusing when I'd have to go you know
back and forth between the two the thing
that infuriated her was that you would
crash your golf cart and your father
would fix it before you could see do you
remember that I do my cousin said I were
giggling recently and we were talking
about how we can't believe that we're
all still alive she and Priscilla would
become closer in later years and at just
21 Lisa Marie became a mom herself first
to daughter Riley and then to son
Benjamin do you worry I I'm always
worried you know what it never ends just
they get into bigger problems yeah
they're getting into the real life
heavier stuff and I'm navigating I'm
watching them both navigate through
stuff and I'm like oh you know but in
2020 Benjamin committed suicide at just
27. Lisa Marie said I will never be the
same please wait for me my love her
final Instagram post from August touched
on an essay she wrote describing her
continuing grief quote I've been living
in the horrific reality of a unrelenting
grips anything happening with them I
feel if they're sick I get sick if
there's something happens to them I'm
going through it it's really a beautiful
but painful situation in 2008 she gave
birth to now and 14 year old twins
Harper and Finley with guitarist and
music producer Michael Lockwood their
contentious relationship split and
custody battle contributed to Lisa
Marie's substance abuse struggles it was
not a good situation but I was kind of
living in a wasp nest I suppose and then
I had the babies and trying to be as
happy as possible not be surrounded by
bad things those bad things included an
addiction to opioid painkillers in 2008
Lisa Marie went to rehab in 2016 but
told us she had always been open with
her kids I think it was 17 the last time
I took I tried any kind of recreational
situation like that um what I do is I'll
tell them the truth and you know what I
wear ladies and what it does and you
know
be really honest about it I would never
let them do anything I did ever
throughout Lisa Marie's many ups and
downs she believed in love and was
married four times I haven't figured it
out yet have I
she was just 20 years old when she wed
musician Danny Keough in 1988 the two
met in drug rehab well Danny it was just
the stability I was very much a homebody
longest relationship that I maintained
shortly after the wedding the couple
announced they were expecting their
first child Riley arrived in 1989.
Benjamin was born three years later Lisa
told me about his striking resemblance
to Elvis
do you ever look at him and say wow all
the time I'll just say you're killing me
right now you're killing me right now
that's why he moves himself also the way
it looks but just his mannerisms are
also very similar Lisa Marie and Danny's
marriage ended after six years three
months after the divorce was finalized
in 1996 this happened and just thinking
nobody thought this would last
when the king of rock and roll's
daughter suddenly eloped with the King
of Pop It triggered a worldwide tabloid
Frenzy
many wondered if the relationship was a
publicity stunt which Lisa Marie always
denied why did you marry Michael then I
fell in love with him I mean I said that
I did I got caught up in his world and
his life came about the idea of him
probably the idea of him we were similar
or compatible the marriage occurred
while Michael was facing allegations of
child molestation Lisa Marie stood by
his side I didn't say to him are they
true no I didn't he went on and on and
on about it so I didn't really have to
say are the allegations true it was you
know your interview together I'd
wondered if you'd seen that since I I
saw it once three years after I did it
do you recognize you nope
I've become a lot stronger not amused
I've seen it all Lisa Marie and
Michael's marriage lasted one and a half
years after Michael's death she told
Oprah the real reason it came crashing
down he had to make a decision was it
the drugs and the and the sort of
vampires or me and he pushed me away how
bad was it when you guys finally said
this isn't going to work it was like
Defcon too it was bad it was very
stressful in 2002 Lisa married another
a-lister Oscar winner Nicholas Cage
we're the same in terms of being really
really dramatic together it's just a
force and it's so intense that it's not
going to ever just be mediocre it's
never going to be something you know
nice and sort of quiet the two first
cross pass at a party in 2000 while she
was engaged to singer-songwriter John
ojika and Nick was married to Patricia
Arquette they wed in Hawaii near the
25th anniversary of Elvis's death but
split less than four months later Lisa
said at the time they shouldn't have
been married in the first place you guys
are still friends you said yes what do
you think your music
from what I gathered he liked it a lot
are there songs about him yeah I don't
know
there's songs about everything did I
duck it and with my hat
Lisa's fourth marriage in 2006 to
musician Michael Lockwood gave her twin
girls who turned 15 this year are they
mommy's girls or Daddy's Girls or one of
each one of each
one of each Finley's Mommy's girl
Harper's Daddy's girl Lockwood's
attorney tells E.T Michael's world has
been turned on its ear and he's focused
on their daughters I am the happiest
that I've ever been in the most sane
calm best relationship I've ever been
for sure but that didn't last their
10-year marriage was shattered in 2016
by what appeared to be her relapse a
ferocious six-year custody battle
followed during which she admitted to
abusing cocaine and mixing pills with
alcohol in 2017 she temporarily lost
custody of her twins I just feel like a
limbs missing if one's not around the
X's battle over finances wasn't over
until late last year at the time of her
death Lisa had her girls 60 of the time
and was reportedly paying Michael 6 000
a month in child support I know now how
quickly it goes so I keep them all close
to me at all times they still need me
but I also need them outside of her
children music was Lisa Marie's his
passion despite her mother's
reservations she was a little nervous
for me to walk down that road why like
big she used to film I don't want to run
or distance from it in any way or seem
disrespectful to it but at the same time
I'm like yeah I want to be an artist too
if I want to do my own thing or I want
to
have some identity of my own
her debut album to whom it may concern
was released in 2003 to critical Acclaim
E.T was backstage as she lived out her
childhood dream performing with Pat
Benatar at VH1's Divas Duets
I was so intimidated when I first got up
there with her I used to be in front of
the mirror with tennis rackets and all
kinds of stuff you know faking that song
for her second album Lisa Marie sang a
duet with pink who paid tribute saying
oh this one hurts my heart the world
lost the rear gem
[Music]
Lisa Marie's third and final album was
the closest to her dad's country Blues
roots
[Music]
I think in the past it's been sort of
pushing me in places I didn't
particularly belong like pop or top 40
or all these things that wasn't really
me her final song was a duet with her
dad in 2018.
[Music]
there's something that was really cool
and intimate and organic about the two
of us in this track I actually had broke
down for a second Lisa Marie was also
devoted to Scientology for much of her
life in 2003 she reportedly asked one of
Danny Masterson's accusers not to go to
police after the woman had alleged the
actor raped her Lisa Marie later
apologized to her friend and left the
church in 2014 telling friends I was
slowly starting to self-destruct they
were taking my soul my money my
everything as for what Lisa Marie's
Legacy will be here's what she told E.T
in her own words I don't know what to do
with myself I'm not if I'm not a mom I
mean that's what I focus on most the
time I love I love them there was so
much about their grandfather out there
but what did you want them to know music
wouldn't
be quite like it is right now if it
wasn't for him he's still alive in all
of us and we're carrying on on for him I
would hope that he would be very proud
of me my biggest wish was that I would
affect people and appreciate it as an
artist
[Music]